o chiesa cure per indossare sia sanità
faremo un video capito che se avete
richiesto giuseppe chiesto di vedere in
un video cosa fa
berlino quando noi non siamo a casa ma
che deve fare non abbiamo idea di cosa
fa quando noi usciamo come facciamo a
saperlo semplice metteremo una
videocamera questo bravi rigore se avete
visto il nostro video che testiamo 4
gadget per cani abbiamo comprato una
pettorina con videocamera e si può
mettere qua sopra l'abbiamo già testate
a berlino non da forti di gru per
fortuna quindi una volta che noi
riusciamo andremo ad azionare la camera
usciremo quindi ci allontaniamo un po
così lui capisce che ci siamo
allontanati altrimenti se noi ci
nascondiamo dietro il cancello cui lo
capirebbe subito intelligente anche se
non si vede siete pronti io sono troppo
curiosa lasciate un bel mi piace se
volete vedere altri video del genere e
consegnati sicure nei commenti che altri
video volete vedere con berlino pronti
passati e pop corn
ecco qua la pettorina quindi come prima
cosa andiamo a vederli la pettorina dai
ragazzi abbiamo messo la pettorina
questo è il proteggi camera ora andiamo
a mettere la camera dentro merlino di
piacere filmato è un po un vanitoso e
poi andiamo a registrare e noi usciamo e
vediamo cosa combina merlino e abbiamo
dovuto dare un po di quello che il tuo
cagnolino di bari nella mostra età un
pochino di più perché lui il cucciolo 80
è molto grande sono cinque mesi berlino
cuccioletto ciao a tutti sono state
dormirò tutto il tempo fatto spogliare
ok ora mettiamo la camera e usciamo
drive o riusciamo anche carino ok ora
lasciamo lo teniamo e vediamo un po cosa
combina
ok stiamo in macchina allora ogni volta
che usciamo in pratica ogni volta che
noi usciamo gli mettiamo delle
crocchette nei suoi giochini così non ci
rincorre e non rischia appunto di
scappare fuori siamo super curiosi di
vedere cosa succede dopo che gli
mettiamo le crocchette perché sappiamo
che lui va verso il cancello ma non
sappiamo cosa fa dopo quanto tempo
aspetta lì quindi siamo troppo curiosi
di vedere poi ok ragazzi sono passati
dieci minuti stiamo tornando vediamo un
po che è piombi nato
per vendola gravi di morti mentre vivo
anche se sente il rumore della macchina
che quando rientriamo lui si corre in
porta ok siamo tornati e abbiamo preso
la schedina dalla camera si berlino
l'abbiamo messa nei computer così ora
rivedremo il video assieme a voi così
vedrete anche la nostra reazione sono
troppo curiosi che cosa avrà combinato
mamma mia
diamo subito ha tra l'altro in questo
caso lo abbiamo lasciato in giardino
merlino perché c'è un bel tempo e caldo
però se volete vedere anche cosa fa se
non lasciamo dentro canna un paio di
regia cielo senza prove per butt state
un bel mi piace e se questo video
raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace faremo
anche quel video
ok allora in questo momento qua vitale
stava mettendo i croccantini a merlino
stavo dando il kong nemico raccontini
davvero bordino per gli over che sembra
di essere sembra di vedere le cose
tramite merlino andrà di essere lui è
fantastico
la prospettiva di berlino e allora ecco
basta mangiato zucca le crocchette dio
in quanto tempo le finisse tutte finite
subito c'è ancora qualcuno che non è
uscito forse ridiamo quando si accorge
che noi stiamo uscendo
[Musica]
ancora non se n'è accorto
sto andando verso lo stendino di ho
paura che ora tutti giù qualche vestito
[Musica]
bello specie ha avviato sta continuando
a cercare le proprie tipo di non si è
accorto che siamo usciti nozze o chiesa
come sito intruppati appena chiuso il
cancello ecco vedete mettiamo in
macchina dall'inquadratura
cielo sereno e si vede così vuol dire
che lui stava seduto perché mai farà
puntava verso l'alto quindi vediamo
cos'altro combina è troppo divertente
poter vedere queste cose non fra
nient'altro eccolo eccolo si muova
destra andando nell'erba stanno nostra
yersey al fresco della serba sotto al
muro sia appoggiato al muro per vedere
quello che fa di nuovo salute si è
sdraiata si è sdraiato battino lavoro è
un po di qua quindi forse sta dormendo a
caldo le mani forza calda si sta
sull'erba fresca troppo divertente farà
adesso non mi dica che dorme per tutto
il tempo
alzando sesso qualcosa forse legato cosa
sentito correndo la scelta è proprio
bello vederlo più amici si gioca intorno
con questione che adotta all'indietro
[Musica]
sono più di vivere la vita del cane e
tratta stico o racket
restano nell'erba meno male non ha
continuato a protestare in sentita male
poverino è quello indicato verso la
camera così sofferta che ci sono sei gli
spettatori che lo stanno guardando
incredibile ora penso che sta proprio
d'ormeggio perché non si vede più la
testa quindi si sarà appoggiato
controllando l'erba 1 faccetta sta
operando un po l'aria niente rilassato e
tranquillo io pensavo che quando noi non
stavamo in casa qui è andato in giro a
distruggere tutte le palle come l'ho
creato a distruggere i giocattoli altro
all'altro mercato anche la seconda palla
che ci abbiamo comprato un musetto
sull'erba a camera si muove anche in
base al suo respiro che si ok ragazzi ha
continuato a dormire per un bel po che
ti abbiamo mandato un po avanti vediamo
ora dovrebbe alzarsi
forse stiamo già tornando senso qualcosa
stiamo tornando
sentite belle case senza invito a
controllando la situazione c'è un gatto
o se provavo sbaglio si è ricaricato
giorni sono controllate se
riaddormentato ok ragazzi allora berlino
continua a dormire poi abbiamo una
bellissima visuale dell'erba dovete tra
jato in genere tra l'altro quando noi
siamo in casa non si sdraia ma in futuro
del giardino non si sdraia mai qua
quindi forse sta proprio qua però
aspettare che noi torniamo a gitando
vediamo questo è sentito qualcosa forse
ci ha sentito tornare orecchiette che
avete da guardare questa mia vita
privata vogliono privacy non lo sta
bussando l'aria sicura voras corredato
di è questo quello che sono stato io
dovetti rispetto che carino
ma se ha sentito che stiamo tornando
come possa ma di ponte si è seduto
nuovamente infatti abbiamo questa
bellissima visuale del cielo noi quando
torniamo permettiamo che torna eccoci
noi sicuramente stiamo tornando perché
berlino si è esposta knox
beh che facciamo siamo messa solenne mai
battuto la camera pur pagando moretto
allora siete persone non ho mai preso
brucerà caldi di no sono troppo caldo
secondo me non si è reso conto è andato
il solo a prendere un po di sole 6
atletico inter cari isola l'erba abbiamo
una visione ancora più ravvicinata
dell'erba possiamo vedere anche la terra
gli insetti che cambino berlino e deve
fare i documentari che sta succedendo
niente ha solo spostato di inquadratura
un pochino più vedere le formiche se
guardiamo attentamente leva quello che
non vermica eccola allora ha alzato un
po la testa forse ora ecco ecco lo so
forse si sta mangiando un pezzo d'erba
la berlina entro lo ha sentito la
macchina no sono sta dall'altra parte
solo questo conto che stavo al solito
fame dalla brava forse sto più fresco
seduto arrivati qui di lui è felicissimo
si sta correndo ai corpi sia successo ma
non si rende conto e sbatte dappertutto
correndo verso vitale sto aspettando che
venga anche evitare da carezza star
abbiamo perché vitale non c'è si sta
preoccupando la difesa e salutava il
feedback come rincari primi contatti
cosa sto facendo sia messo a propiziare
il non me lo potevo prendere orecchietta
che semina copyright ma lo molla ma è un
testardo né
li lasciano però non molla e trova tra
piante al questo vizio di andare al
rosmarino esistiamo divertisi troppo
vedere cosa fa a berlino quando non
siamo in casa veramente stato troppo
divertente patatona che dorme sempre st
bigazzi se volete vedere anche cosa fa a
berlino quando rimane da solo destro
casa avremo delle belle che li riguarda
di esistere nei commenti il minuto che
vi ha divertito di più quindi asine più
due minuti 2.30 eccetera eccetera così
il time stamp così noi andiamo a
rivederli e grideremo un sarto e ora vi
lasciamo qua 4 candeline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video il caldo
su quella che preferite e vorrei
visitare nel cielo
perché
no
pezzo
[Musica]